this small revolution in English
politics these are the streets where the
voices have demanded to be heard and it
isn't hard to work out why the story of
the working poor in this country gets
worse with every passing year in the
sixth richest country in the world
people who work in places like hospitals
or factories are relying on someone to
give them essentials for their babies
because they can't afford to buy them
this church has been taken over by the
sheer need most shockingly of all they
told us these little packets of baby
food aren't being eaten by infants but
by their parents parents are sacrificing
their own health and equally their
nutrition by making sure so so so so
they need that so the children don't
have to yeah exactly I need and also to
make sure that their children got the
food that they need and these are these
are working people working people yes
definitely definitely that's it's just
absolutely extraordinary it is
extraordinary since the election all the
analysis has suggested the vote for the
Conservatives in places like this came
almost entirely from older white people
who may or may not still be around to
see brexit eventually get done even so
the Conservatives know they have to do
something for these communities it
expects it to be absolutely
inconceivable that places like this
would vote for anybody but the labour
party but in this election not just a
few places but almost everywhere in the
Midlands and north of England chose to
vote conservative instead and that
represents the most amazing opportunity
for the Conservatives
to redraw forever the political map of
England but only if brexit becomes a
hugely important vehicle for social
change
we've been tracking stoke-on-trent since
people like Ali ensured it voted to
leave the European Union over three
years ago since then
Ali has changed her mind and regrets her
votes and she doesn't trust the
Conservatives to change Stokes fortunes
there's not a lot here anymore
and I want to know what they're going to
do for it from our city you know
I want to know what what are they going
to do for us because this is a city
that's broken and it needs repairing so
look around huge amounts of the North
look like this with pockets of
successful industry next divisions of
post-industrial despair the
Conservatives have always been blamed by
so many for causing this damage but now
they are in charge of putting it right
people would welcome any more job
security and also probably higher pay
jobs you know we still a relatively low
wage economy no matter what cept here n
so anything that can bring some more
affluent and prosperity to the
businesses which will then cascade
through the workforce will be more than
welcome a next Christmas the UK will be
out of the European Union the Prime
Minister has made himself answerable to
the parents of the children who will get
one suite for Christmas this year and a
little Troy as well if he can't make
brexit work with them it will have
failed Laurence Lee al-jazeera
stoke-on-trent